Squat checklist.
If you take all five,
you have a perfect squat.
First, check bar placement.
For a high bar squat,
place the bar on your upper traps.
This will target slightly more quads.
For a low bar squat,
shift the bar down 2 or 3 inches.
This will target slightly more glutes and low back.
Second, an efficient walkout.
Don't take too many steps.
That's just wasted energy.
Instead, take one step to clear the rack.
Second step to match the other foot,
and a third adjustment step
if you need to get them even. Third,
stance width.
Narrow and wide stances both work,
but for most people,
just outside shoulder width
with slightly flared toes is best.
Fourth, depth.
Try to break parallel for the best gains,
but cutting depth a bit shy won't kill your gains.
For powerlifting,
you do need to get your hip crease
below your knee joint for the lift to count.
Squat shoes and ankle mobility drills,
dropping the weight back can help you get deeper.
Fifth, a good bar path.
Ideally, the bar should travel in a straight line
centered over the middle of your foot.
If it shifts a bit,
that's okay.
Try to keep it in balance the best you can.
Now you have my.